(relaxing music)
- [Tyler] To be able to be
doing science while you're out
there on the surfboard surfing
down the face of a wave,
it's just such a fleeting moment.
It's incredible to
actually be able to do it.
(upbeat music)
- A Smartfin is a surfboard fin.
You clip it on the bottom of your board
and you go out for your surf session.
It has technology that
measures ocean pH salinity,
ocean temperature, and very
detailed wave characteristics.
So there will be an
enormous amount of data.
The reason these parameters
are important is because
they are shifting directly as
a result of climate change.
We get detailed information
about the deep ocean
but very limited accurate
information about the near shore.
Satellites can't be really accurate
with data in that narrow zone.
And the other way is ocean buoys
and they're just not
deployed at the coast.
Bingo, Smartfin can fill that gap.
- Collecting oceanic data is a very
time consuming, expensive process.
This is like, you just
need to know how to surf.
The data moves from your fin
to your phone via Bluetooth.
And then from your phone
it goes up to our servers
where everything's processed.
I had to develop sensors that
don't affect the surfboard.
Nobody's gonna surf a fin
that is not a standard foil.
Aside from that LED right
there that's blinking
that tells you that there's like
some sort of technology in there,
you wouldn't know the difference.
So we've got a test tank set up now.
And we're just trying
to look at the precision
and accuracy of the, um, instrument itself.
Things are looking pretty promising.
As a scientist it's pretty
exciting to be able to get data
over these different
time and space scales.
I mean the fact that
you can go out and surf
and contribute to understanding
what's actually happening
out there is incredible.
- I'm not a surfer, I know
nothing about surfing.
I know I look like a surfer, but I'm not.
Surfers are very influential
and care deeply about the environment
and want to be talking about it.
So Smartfin is just a tool to do that
in a more concrete way.